so now I have a value 4 over here right
I'm just going to write this one hundred
and forty two point eight well not a lot
I've put this down here because it
corresponds to this right here's another
school right you use your diagrams as a
tool they're not just there to look
pretty though they should look pretty
right there there is a mechanism to help
you solve the question right so now I
know this you can see from the diagram
now all I need to do is this right
that's all that's left and the process
is exactly the same people taught me
through it what I start writing I'll
give you a clue it starts with in in
triangle BC - very good
so I'm naming my triangle got another
one over there okay because my setup is
exactly the same right I have an angle
of elevation and I had that same
literally the same distance hundred
meters the flagpole Manson
anyway I'm caught 1022 right and I've
got the same relationship
so again you're gonna get BC is the
subject hundred 1022 and you're going to
get out and you know but go ahead
country for me you should get two
hundred and something from memory 247
okay now mm-hmm
247 give me a few decimal places give me
a triple okay now I'll just mention
again you get secretly saying this but
hopefully that means that you really get
it right I'm putting these calculator
displays down not because they
necessarily merit much not because all I
have to but because I'm trying to
demonstrate that I know exactly where
this number came from right
you can't fluke this number right you
can like you can copy off someone's like
you know if they just rounded that 243
or something like that you copy out US
on the sheet and not have any idea where
it came from but when you have the
decimal places it puts it beyond a
shadow of a doubt that you put exactly
the right thing in your calculator so
you're communicating that you understand
the process okay same deal use your
store button right shift store checking
in babe I guess and you'll have the
answer going into B and then you're done
now I've got my second distance that I
needed to 4705 so you can see what we've
done now right we transformed a problem
that we didn't know how to solve 3d tree
into a problem that we do know how to
solve in fact it's trivially easy to
solve this is just Pythagoras okay you
know how to do pie that you can do in a
few years let's just tie this up in a
neat book okay again in a particular
triangle right because they're all right
angled so I'd better name what's going
on I'm after a date so a B squared
equals let's name these guys
as 5.3 students you always should attach
geometric reasoning to what's going on
in fact that's one of the key
differences between a 5.3 and a 5.2
student a fuck-boy Tristan can crunch
through processes but might not actually
understand will be able to articulate
the reasons why so Pythagoras theorem
that's why this is the case okay so when
you go to here right you have a couple
of choices I'm just going to put down
these like rough numbers 100 points you
point something but in your calculator
all you need to do is now to manipulate
these numbers I showed you how to recall
them right but I'm clearly display clear
at all and because these are all
alphabetical characters you use up in
the top left alpha right see if you go
alpha and then a there's your character
and then you just need to square it
right so alpha a squared you'll have a
squared in your display then you add B
and then you square it and you'll have a
squared plus B squared in there okay so
obviously choose letters that are
convenient to you so you don't confuse
them you should get a number at the end
right some big number someone's got it
for me I said you can come eight one six
five six and some decimal places do you
have
okay great so I'm almost there this
number is ridiculously large right and
the reason why is because it's the
distance squared okay so with that
number still you just play it
all you have to do is plug the square
root button now I already worked this
one out so I got 285 point okay now I'm
pretty much done on iron which is one
exception are you carefully that was a
very first tip that I gave you wake up
there we go what I need to do I have
some approximation to do right and you
will notice I have waited all the way to
the very end to approximate what would
have happened if I had for instance
approximated here or here what effect
would that have had anyone here Chris oh
yeah exactly right every time you
introduce like a little bit of deviation
it literally be a point to here or point
five there but don't forget you're
squaring those numbers any areas you
introduced they tend to inflate and what
you're going to end up with the bottom
it's going to be different okay so now
at the very end this and only this is
what I approximate I do um a squiggly
equal sign that you can just as easily
do this the reason I don't do that is
because when I'm in an exam and in a
hurry my dots look like well they look
like this so I don't do dots okay
squiggly lines hard to screw those up so
that means approximately equals two two
eight six and you should say the unit's
that you will approximately two
happy times